actually all right let's find out what
the next category is best trash taste
moment
in general let's have a look at the
nominees of the best trash taste moment
god there's so many to choose from oh
this is this is when this is when it
gets
really really [ __ ] hard i love um i
love how
the first two are from the their hands
most of these we don't actually need to
play because you've already yeah
we've already i mean i i feel like when
when we made this this was just like
the highlight reel of some of the best
moments that had got nominated
from other categories so we obviously we
got the korean or uh gangbang debate
conor mother knows breast debate rare
soul carrying god's figure challenge win
the great burger debate
uh page two uh me coming out
mailings three by three and the bidet
debate that revolves at the time bidet
debate
i don't even know honestly i i'm i'm
biased mother knows breast has a special
place in my heart yeah honestly any of
these could win man i
it's like picking between your children
um this is way too hard for me there's
so many iconic moments
that have happened throughout the year
and none of these were planned
yeah they they just like i i'd say the
only one out of all these that we knew
what was coming was the
new or gangbang debate because i knew
because we planned that i knew
i knew we were going to lose our [ __ ]
minds over that and we did
it into a great like it was it was one
of the moments where i knew something
was going to happen and i'm glad that it
kind of lived up to what was going to
happen in my mind
definitely um god i guess there's only
one way to find out really
let's just should we just start with
this all right i really don't know this
is one of the biggest awards
the viewers decided for the best trash
taste of uh i guess
2020 20 season 20 season 1 21 i guess
season one season one just keep it
simple all right keep it simple the best
moment of season one of trash taste
is create a drumroll in post mudan it is
oh it's upside down
what is it moonlight finding nemo
the best trash taste moment of the year
season one
is connor's mother nose restaurant
[Music]
wow really wow i wasn't i'm not
surprised because that is the one that
to this day i still get people
talking to me about it people always
talk to me about mother nose breasts
that
and i feel like it's such a visceral
eclipse
it's such a it's like oh god that's not
a clip you can share with the family no
no no no no
yeah i mean i'm not surprised that one
won
when they all played i'm like yeah i
think this one's gonna work
because all the other ones are good
don't get me wrong but yeah i'll give
you a reaction
at least from the viewers perspective
what was the percentage on this one this
one one with 19.8 oh
it's closed 19.8 that's so close
and what was second place well second
place
of course
joey's coming out moment wow what an
amazing moment that was great
amazing i'm glad i did yeah yeah wow all
right